I was astonished
anybody is willing to go to the map for
that set of values anymore but of course
I know that people are and yeah I don't
like the idea that I'm being polite to a
person and that's not in accordance with
my values
all right we're not doing a normal intro
today I think you might know this guy
Russell Brand welcome to the Reuben
report here in locals in Miami on your
American tour thanks for having me on
the Reuben report
pretty good we got our own mugs you can
have that you want to keep that mug yes
please I'd like to sign it and I'd like
to I'll keep it as a Memento of a
already lovely occasion just arriving
here and meeting everyone it's been so
lovely you're bouncing all over the
place man it's been it's been a wacky
week do you have like a word that would
sum up what has happened since you got
to America the Bill Maher thing and then
you've done 800 shows and all over the
place what what word would sum it up for
you this is a dude like it's sort of
like a vacillating
undulating or shape-shifting state
altering kind of it's like it's been
it's interesting isn't it mate because
we're aware rather than the Vanguard of
the political conversation would you
want to be where where else would you
want to be but the truth is is that I
don't do well with antagonism I don't do
well with it I don't care for it much
you know I don't I prize Serenity very
highly I don't really particularly enjoy
being at the center of
uh uh of incendry matters nor do I enjoy
being criticized like say if you ask
someone for feedback this is what I mean
you'll go oh have you got any feedback
do you know what I actually mean can you
give me a series of very sincere and
specific compliments now that's what I
mean I see it's sincere and specific
compliments the way you did that was
brilliant that yeah thank you then I can
sort of sit and reflect on it as if I'm
like with studying something that's uh
uh objective and external I don't like
to feel attacked in particular perhaps
nobody does I long ago due to the nature
of uh celebrity have broadly elected to
extract myself from the discourse about
me uh deciding
as is suggested in my program uh what
other people think of me is none of my
business what other people think of me
it's none of my business you can do what
you want in your mind that's yours or
you could even say what you want it's
none of my it's none of my business it's
abstract but of course like on the level
of um how I actually feel I am like all
of us I'm sure a well-intentioned person
and I am optimistic about human beings
and I'm trying to do something that I
feel is important yeah and perhaps I
hope I'm doing it well but of course
with no way of knowing isn't it kind of
funny like someone that doesn't Court
the controversy and then you have a
moment like that real time which
actually why don't we just throw to it
real quick everyone's seen it a million
times we'll throw to it
it's disingenuous to claim that the
biases they're exhibited on Fox News are
any different
on
see it's
addictions operate as anything other
than mouthpieces for their affiliate
owners in BlackRock and Vanguard and
unless we start to embrace and it also
mate like just spiritually if I may use
that word in your great country we have
to take responsibility for our own
perspective I've been on that MSNBC mate
it was propaganda it's not crackery
good morning Joe it was absurd The Way
They Carried morning jokes yeah I don't
know what it was it wasn't morning there
was no one called Joe there no one could
concentrate they didn't understand the
basic tennis of Journalism no one was
willing to stick up for genuine American
Heroes uh like Edward Snowden no one was
willing to talk about Julian Assange and
what he suffered trying to bring real
journalism to the American people and I
think to sit within the castle of MSNBC
throwing rocks have Fox News is
ludicrous make MSNBC the moment that you
give me a specific example I'd ask
assistant
just specific examples
I'd like to hear a specific example
approval specific example of an MSNBC
correspondent or anchor being on
television saying something they knew
was false and we're saying behind the
scenes to his people this is I'm about
to go out and we know that we know that
the election wasn't stolen
but I will go but I will go out I will
go out on television and say the
opposite I will lie where's my answer
just give me up give me the specific
example give me a specific example all
right I'm with you I think it's a false
equivalency
it's not about bias it's a policy
because you don't actually know anything
about any of these organizations you're
talking about even an MSNBC once big
deal my darling it was more than
enough
great single you have a single actual
fact do you want an example do you want
an example the ludicrous outrageous
criticisms of Joe Rogan around
Ivermectin deliberately referring to his
medicine when they know it's not
effective medicine
if you take this vaccine you're not
gonna get it when it hasn't been
clinically responsible you have to
listen wait do you think you can improve
America like determinable and a validly
condemning Fox News without
acknowledging that you're participating
in the same game did you not just listen
to Bernie Sanders some who plainly
legitimately believes in this country
and believes it's possible to change but
is bound by corruption is bound by the
lobbying system surely it's clear to you
Bill as one of the great pundits and
experts and comic voices that systemic
changes required money has to be taken
out of politics we need new political
systems that genuinely represent all the
ordinary Americans so that we can
overcome cultural differences and
bickering about which propagandist
network is the worst is not going to
save a single American life not improve
the life of a single American child not
going to approve America's standing in
the world and the world needs a strong
America I'll tell you that I'll tell you
that so you have an obligation a duty
not to condemn these people you weren't
being a dick I mean that's the thing you
were trying to say something very true
something that most of us are we know
about media and everything but then it
gets turned into like this destruction
of this guy and and I probably even feed
into some of that when I cover it on my
show like man that guy kind of deserved
to get wrecked but it wasn't it wasn't
really about him you weren't trying to
make it about him that was very clear I
was astonished
anybody is willing to go to the mat for
that set of values anymore but of course
I know that people are and yeah I don't
like the idea that I'm being polite to a
person and that's not in accordance with
my values but you weren't really being
impolite you you were being passionate
right like you weren't you weren't rude
to him I don't think I think you were
you were confident in what you were
saying and it needed to be said yeah I
feel we can't move forward with the
conversation from like it happens in
politics doesn't it you know when they
say oh well this is only happening this
is the last Administration done that
this is because CNN or Fox News or
whatever it's like well why don't we
focus on what we're contributing
individually or if we claim to be the
representative of some sort of movement
class culture or advocacy group perhaps
then we can look at how if we claim to
speak on behalf of them and certainly I
make no such claim then we should look
after ourselves and our own conduct and
because that has Gandhi said I find I am
such a sinner in my own life I'm not
confident when it comes to judging
others I try to monitor my own behavior
but I am engaged in punditry I am
engaged in commentary so you know like
and as as I said I suppose in that
conversation it's not like I
particularly aligned with Fox News as an
institution in fact I have a rather
colorful history with that organization
right right so when you were preparing
for the show or they're telling you you
know they do obviously they do a
pre-interview with you or you pass that
point uh we kept trying to do it but I
kept not doing it so I kept not doing
the pre interview right you knew what
the topics were going to be right
no I knew like uh what happened they
said that they were gonna they said that
that might come up actually they said I
thought that they said we would talk
about the pandemic and then I think that
they said that there was a possibility
that uh the changing nature of the
relationship between Fox News and Trump
would come up
and and so I suppose it was within the
orbit of that topic that the Contra Tom
around the distinctions between a
neo-liberal establishment media and
neoconservative establishment media was
discussed yeah it was so interesting
because when he was trying to get you
like give me the one right like he was
trying to give me give me one time that
they intentionally lied and it's like
man we could do this all day very fine
people on both sides Brett Kavanaugh is
a serial rapist the Covington kids or
races I mean I do this on my show every
day you went with the Rogan one and it's
like you didn't it just didn't have much
after he wanted to but does it get to
that point of like it's weird that
anyone defends it is that really what
you think this is about I'm starting to
come to that too that it's hard to
defend at this point
I've this is where I'm at Dave
I'm at why don't we now acknowledge that
there are different ways of being a
human and call a kind of Truth and
accept that there are some people for
this for the sake of Simplicity that
there are progressive ways of being a
human being there are traditional ways
of being a human being neither of those
ways are wrong why don't we allow one
another to express ourselves how we want
to within the obvious bounds of consent
and then perhaps we can organize
different alliances so that we can
organize around the systems of
centralized power that will else wise
continue to dominate and annihilate if
you're looking for more uncensored
opinions from today's thought leaders
check out our media playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a wide
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell